[Musique]
les francos moisin à saint denis c'était
il ya quatre ans l'un des plus grands
bidonvilles de la région parisienne au
printemps prochain il sera remplacé par
une pelouse et la plupart de ses
habitants iront s'installer dans les hlm
d'en face oui c'est vrai en france dans
moins de deux ans les grands bidonvilles
auront disparu mais trente cinq mille
personnes vivent encore aujourd'hui dans
le carton et la tôle ondulée
mais un million de noirs de portugais
d'algériens et de français vivent encore
dans des taudis
c'est la misère crasse des banlieues et
des vieux quartiers que révèle de temps
à autre la pioche des démolisseurs
depuis quelques années on ne se contente
plus de casser les bidonvilles de casser
les taudis pour chasser cette misère
ailleurs en trois ans le montant des
crédits de l'état pour la résorption de
l'habitat insalubre a été multipliée par
six cette année 125 millions et en trois
ans le nombre des logements des cités de
transit et des foyers travailler en a
cessé de croître
mais aujourd'hui si l'on possède
l'argent les crédits nécessaires
on doit faire face à un problème qui
devient inquiétant celui des terrains en
ville la place coûte cher de plus en
plus cher et les municipalités ne cède
pas volontiers leur terrain pour loger
des noirs ou des portugais loger des
immigrés c'est très bien dit en mai elle
est plutôt construire chez le maire
voisin et c'est pourquoi ils auront
peut-être demain logement décent mais un
logement qu'ils devront quitter plus tôt
que les autres pour se rendre sur le
chantier
[Musique]